good morning John and welcome to the
special edition of vlogbrothers where we
discuss the basics of the United States
Tax Policy why Warren Buffett pays a
lower tax rate than his secretary
according to the matter States
government there are basically three
ways to make money one you can inherit
it when someone dies two you can make it
by working this is called ordinary
income making money off youtube ads
getting paid to do a job making raw
materials like yarn and then converting
something worth more than those raw
materials like a gold tiffy owes hat
that's all ordinary income and number
three capital gains now before we talk
about capital gains let's first talk
about the ordinary income tax some
people have a misconception here that
when you reach the new tax bracket all
of your income lumps over into this new
place so you have to stay below a
certain tax bracket that's not how it
works it's actually a significantly
better system than that here we have the
four lowest tax brackets for a married
couple now if you make $10,000 a year
you pay 10% tax you probably pay less
than that because of deductions but
that's that's your tax rate because the
first tax bracket is 0 to $17,000 now if
a married couple makes $50,000 they've
moved into the second tax bracket but
still their first $17,000 is taxed in
the first tax bracket and then the rest
is taxed in the second this works on up
the scale for $100,000 and when I made
this graph I had to make it extra long
to fit on $500,000 which includes all of
the tax brackets but even that person
that makes $500,000 still pays into all
of the lower tax brackets before they
get to their big high up once just
wanted to clear that up now back to
capital gains capital gains is money
that you get when you buy something and
then you wait and then you sell it later
for more that's income you've made money
there most capital gains are made in the
stock market though you can also do a
lots of other ways real estate being a
big one if you make more than like
$30,000 a year your capital gains tax is
15% it's a flat 15% for everybody and
basically capital gains is how really
rich people make most of their money
they invest in stuff and then it gets
more valuable and then they sell it now
that's basically explaining how it works
now I'm gonna get into how I feel about
it this is just my opinion this is has
always seemed really weird to me money
in the stock market isn't actually doing
anything companies don't have access to
like do stuff with that it's not being
used to build cars or go to Mars or make
video games or whatever I know that
investment is important for our economy
but so is income income is to me it
seems like it's worth more why is it
then
we tax people almost invariably more on
the money that they earned by providing
actual value like proportionate to the
amount of money they make the idea is
that investment should be really good
for the economy and that you need to
encourage people to invest and so you
should tax it less the problem with that
is that there isn't a lot of good data
that actually supports that claim what
kind of concerns me is that the people
who are advising the government on these
tax policy decisions are people who make
their money this way and maybe they just
like a lot of us do over value their
particular impact on the American
endeavor or maybe they're super greedy
or maybe on the other hand they're right
maybe they're right maybe lower taxes
for them is better for all of us but I
can't help but feeling deep down that
it's tremendously unfair that a waitress
at Applebee's pays a higher tax rate
than a billionaire whether or not that's
good policy I'm not sure but it does
seem like bad ethics but as I say I am
NOT an expert and I'm completely willing
to be convinced that I'm wrong
nerdfighteria you are not wrong because
you kicked John's goal in the butt right
out of the park you kicked it in the
butt out of the park that's a mixed
sports metaphor a million dollars raised
for Kiva before I even got to make my
first video promoting it but please
still keep going because one thing that
is proven economically is that
microfinance is a really great way to
help the developing world and you can be
a part of that through Kiva org John
I'll see you on Tuesday